[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con este viernes
13 de agosto con noruega méxico y rusia
como observadores inician en ciudad de
méxico un nuevo intento de negociación
entre el gobierno de venezuela y
sectores de la oposición tras una crisis
política continua durante casi dos
décadas la oposición intenta garantizar
su participación en un proceso de
elecciones libres y transparentes
mientras que nicolás maduro pide que se
levanten las sanciones internacionales
así como la legitimidad en el exterior
para compensar del tema está con
nosotros arturo peraza eres sacerdote
jesuita abogado politólogo vicerrector
de la extensión guayana de la
universidad católica andrés bello
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 hay mucha expectativa por esta
nueva sentada entre el chavismo y los
sectores de la oposición en venezuela
después de cuatro intentos el primero
fue en 2002 o con el presidente
fallecido mucha vez y no se logró nada y
en cambio se profundizó la crisis social
y económica hay una voluntad real de
negociar que podría marcar la diferencia
en esta oportunidad
es difícil decirlo yo siento que del
lado del gobierno es bastante complicado
hablar de un proceso de voluntad real de
negociación ellos siguen hablando de la
palabra diálogo en los términos del
gobierno diálogo simplemente significa
hablar sin que eso llegue a ninguna
conclusión necesariamente por el otro
lado el conjunto de gestos que ha habido
antes de este proceso han sido bastante
fuertes han buscado en definitiva volar
la posibilidad de establecer esta mesa
por lo que uno siente que el gobierno ha
sido forzado a sentarse en la mesa
finalmente ha aceptado pero el camino
por recorrer que queda muy muy largo
porque la distancia entre ambas
posiciones también es extensa el
gobierno pretende simplemente la simple
rendición por parte de la oposición en
términos de aceptación de su legitimidad
y la eliminación de las sanciones
prácticamente con condiciones mínimas
por parte del gobierno y por el otro
lado la pretensión de la oposición es la
sustitución del gobierno
nicolás maduro no está dispuesto a dar y
tocaba un tema muy importante arturo
esta es una estrategia nicolás madura
entonces para ganar tiempo y legitimidad
de cara a las elecciones estatales del
mes de noviembre
bueno yo lo que siento es que el
gobierno venezolano tiene la necesidad
de ambos digamos un intento por buscar
algún camino para lograr los dos
objetivos que tú bien señalas te estás
buscando al gobierno el tema de la
legitimidad internacional es una
situación que ha golpeado muy
fuertemente al gobierno venezolano para
la práctica mayoría de los países del
hemisferio occidental no reconoce ni a
maduro ni su asamblea nacional porque
fuera un procedimiento absolutamente
ilegítimo en su elección y por el otro
lado el establecimiento de sanciones
tiene asfixiada a la economía venezolana
debo decir que si bien esto afecta al
gobierno también afecta seriamente a la
población por el otro lado este la
oposición en definitiva si tiene interés
en que se llegue a una negociación
porque la pregunta que había
implementado al principio en la era
trompista de un supuesto golpe de timón
que terminaría tumbando a maduro con
acuerdo dentro de ciertos sectores del
chavismo nunca resultó cierto y yo creo
que han descubierto que no tienen otra
alternativa sino negociar con nicolás
maduro
y tener que llegar a un acuerdo con él y
ella estaba un actor clave que era
leopoldo lópez que pasó con lópez y
henrique capriles que bajaron el perfil
en estos últimos meses tras haber sido
en el pasado dos caras fuertes contra el
chavismo y el mag durísmo estarán sus
ideas en esta mesa de negociaciones
recordemos además que ahorita leopoldo
lópez está refugiado en españa diferente
henrique capriles y henrique capriles
que sigue en la ciudad de caracas si
ambos están representados en esa mesa yo
no han ido directamente pero sin duda de
waldo y el que representa voluntad
popular en esa mesa sin duda está
expresando la voluntad de lo que él
leopoldo lópez como lidera está pensando
y por el otro lado también en la mesa
sin duda hay una representación por
parte de enrique capriles entonces
evidentemente ambos sectores están
representados en esa mesa son
considerados en esa mesa por lo que
además recuerda que está un grupo muy
fuerte que es acción democrática
es el líder que es en reclamo salud
también tiene un peso fundamental en
este proceso de negociación no solamente
puedes ver a los artistas que aparecen a
veces en los medios hay sujetos que
mantienen un nivel de poder mucho más
importante y quizás no son tan
mediáticos arturo complicada entonces la
situación que pintan estos diálogos
porque usted estaba diciendo pues no es
muy viable que se estanquen las cosas
como están ahora en venezuela y como
llegan tanto el chavismo y la oposición
a negociar en mexico veremos lo que pasa
gracias por su tiempo por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 que tenga usted un
feliz resto de día y ustedes gracias por
siempre estar conectados con nosotros
[Música]